Women actually don't need to do everything that men do.
We don't need a seat at every table.
We don't need to be involved in every industry.
We don't need to be upset
when an industry is dominated by males.
We just don't.
Let me explain.
Today I had to get two new tires put on my car,
and every single person at the tire store was a male.
And tire stores are boring.
So boring. It was freezing cold outside.
The tools are all greasy.
It seems so complicated.
And if we're being totally honest,
women generally don't wanna do that.
I also had a pest control company come
and spray the outside of the house
just to make sure that there's no scorpions around here,
because we have scorpions here.
And the stories that I was hearing
from the pest control technicians blew my mind.
They were telling me about rats
and about cockroaches and snakes and things
that. I'm like,
that sounds horrible.
Again, another industry I don't wanna be part of.
I also saw some construction workers out again
in the freezing cold
doing their thing.
Looked awful.
The point is,
there are a lot of things in this world that women
generally don't wanna do.
It's true of a lot of blue collar jobs,
a lot of white collar jobs,
a lot of hobbies and activities and interest.
Society sends girls and women this message
that we need to be out there
competing against men.
And also this message
that we need to be represented in every industry.
And nobody really ever stops and asks why.
We have plenty of men around.
Let's let them do those things.
They enjoy doing those things.
They wanna do those things.
They are good at those things.
Men and women are very different.
We are good at different things.
We enjoy doing different things.
And that is not only just a fact of life,
that is a good thing.
Those differences are what makes the world go around.
Women don't want to do everything that men can do,
and that's okay.